مشاهدينا تجدد القتال في اقليم دار فورا
المطرب غرب السودان يبدو انه اتخذ ابعادا
قبليه معارك عنيفه واشتباكات وصفاتها
الامم المتحده بالدميه شهدتها مدينه
الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور على مستوى
هذه النقطه من الخريطه بين عناصر الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع مستخدمين مختلفه انواع
الاسلحه القتال العنيف تحول الى النزاع
بين قابلتين وهي قبيله المساليد الافريقيه
وفي المقابل القبائل العربيه واستخدمت في
هذا النزاع الاسلحه الثقيله عشرات القتلى
من المدنيين سقطوا مئات الجرحى اصيبوا ولم
يتم اسعافهم بسبب صعوبه الاوضاع الامنيه
وانتشار المسلحين القبليين في اجزاء واسعه
من مدينه الجنينه عدا عن تزايد اعمال نهب
للمؤسسات الحكوميه ومقارا منظمه الامنيه
وسوق الجنينه وحرق عدد كبير من الم وفقه
مسؤولين في حكومه غرب دارفور الى جانب
توزيع الاسلحه بين المجتمعات المحليه ما
يزيد من الفوضى والعنف هذه التطورات دفعت
بعدد من سكان الجنينه الى الفرار باتجاه
الحدود السودانيه على مستوى هذا الخط من
تشاد او مسودان الى باتجاه تشاد رغم اغلاق
الحكومه هناك للحدود ومنذ عقدين يعيش
اقليم دارفور اضطرابات امنيه كبيره
تخللتها انتهاكات واسعه تسببت بمقتل قرابه
الثلاثه الف شخص وتسببت بنزوحي مليونين
وخمسمائه الف شخصا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات